charles gave président de l'institut des
libertés bonsoir shales gas charles gave
merci d'être avec nous en direct diminue
c'est donc au chômage partiel le
chiffres donnent le tournis six
entreprises sur dix touchés en clair
c'est une barre symbolique inquiétante
pour vous c'est bien entendu ce qui se
passe c'est que vous avez des fonds
propres pour résister à des coups durs
mais la réalité c'est quand votre
chiffre d'affaires 10 par exemple sont
insuffisants donc l'idée du gouvernement
de rang pas de payer une partie des
serres où te parler des salaires est une
bonne idée
le problème c'est que ça reste à
résoudre le problème de fond qui est que
la rentabilité des entreprises
françaises est insuffisant en gros ça
veut dire quoi vous dites c'est une
bonne payer une idée de payer mais la
rentabilité n'est pas suffisante qu'elle
serait donc la solution vous envoyer une
belle il faut s'il voulait vraiment
éviter d'entrer sans cesse d'augmenter
aujourd'hui les frais mais pour les uns
trop ministre française sont quasiment
le le double des frais payés par les
entreprises allemandes ou britanniques
on leur a collé des tas de trucs exemple
tout simple il ya à peu près aujourd'hui
en france quand quelqu'un est payé et
coûte à son entreprise entre 2 et 2 et
demi ce qui est la folie dans le même
temps la france est extrêmement
généreuse en ce moment on vient de le
dire
six entreprises sur dix toucher la
moitié des salariés en chômage partiel
c'est très généreux de la part de l'état
pour ses salariés
je veux dire que l'état est généreux
c'est toujours humide et un peu
intéressante mais farfelu parce que
l'état ça n'est jamais que le pays andin
pour donc ça veut dire que
prendre l'argent aux payeurs d'impôts de
demain pour le donner aujourd'hui mais à
dire que l'état généreux c'est une
plaisanterie de l'état il produit pas
grand chose ce qu'il fait là pour
l'instant c'est qu'il emprunte de
l'argent que nos petits enfants
rembourseront c'est très bien parce
qu'en effet on est un aréna cas de force
majeure mais dire que l'état est
généreux ça ne veut strictement rien
dire puisque l etat c c'est nous il veut
pas y a pas quelqu'un qui s'appelle
leila qui créent de la richesse et des
billets s'est pas l'oncle picsou avec
sont à l'heure c'est l'état c'est une
abstraction qui est censé nous gérer
mais certainement pas de créer de la
richesse
vous avez l'assurance aujourd'hui enfin
vous en êtes convaincu en tout cas que
nécessairement qui va payer à la fin ce
sera nous via l'impôt où il y aura
peut-être d'autres solutions
privilégiées par le gouvernement sait
que la pression fiscale est déjà la plus
élevée en france vous pouvez vous poser
une bonne question c'est que l'emprunt
comme tout le monde devrait le savoir
c'est de la fois différé d'au classes
qui vont les payer comme sont des êtres
un x3 est relativement long terme ceux
qui vont payer c'est ceux qui ne votent
pas c'est à dire les enfants qui sont
pas nés encore un petit peu intéressant
comme idée mais comme l'argent gratuit
ça n'existe pas malgré ce que les gens
ont l'air de croire bassine de lâcher du
pouvoir d'achat dans l'économie qui n'a
pas été gagnée il ya quelqu'un qui va
payer la différence quand c'est possible
un repas gratuit ça n'existe pas charles
gave est que pour le coup le
gouvernement avait d'autre choix que de
faire ça aujourd'hui
le choix est toujours le même c'est
beaucoup trop tard parce que la plupart
des entreprises en europe dans des fonds
propres est solide
la marge brute d'auto film
ce moment des entreprises françaises
c'est à peu près la moitié de ce qu'elle
est pour l'allemagne et vous pour la
grande bretagne d'autres
quand vous avez une entreprise anglaise
une entreprise allemande vous avez des
fonds propres qui vous permettent de
tenir le choc
là vous en avez pas vous n'avez pas
parce que le gouvernement veut à tout
prix donc le gouvernement maintenant
vous donne de l'argent pour prendre de
choc mais c'est pas être généreux et pop
il aurait mieux fait de ne pas commencer
par prendre d'argent et on aurait tous
beaucoup mieux donc ce qu'il faut c'est
simplement à la réforme de l'état sans
vouloir dire de méchant ce thème nous
sommes vraiment aujourd'hui
ou comme on l'a vu les hôpitaux ne
marchent pas la police marche pas comme
on le voit en lui en ce moment l'armée
c'est très moyen la diplomatie il y en a
plus l'enseignement national n'en
parlons plus et andré le pays plus
imposée du monde doc vous dit
tranquillement mais c'est à dire on va
l'argent surtout quand on sait tout
faire l'argent c'est la seule question
importante
donc la seule en grand la seule
ressource qu'on peut sur la captive
aujourd'hui c'est le gaspillage étatique
il faut supprimer le gaspillage et tadic
pour rembourser tous ces prêts qui nous
sont que la conséquence du gaspillage
étatiques alors justement finissons sur
ce prêt 40 milliards d'euros de prêts et
garanties par l'état 1 viala la bpi
accordés aux entreprises en difficulté
votre réaction nécessaire pas suffisant
ben s'il voulait céder deux hommes c'est
déjà ça c'est mieux que rien mais si
vous croyez vous avez un problème de
trous qui est ponctuelle on les
entreprises dans leurs années dans votre
ponctualité un problème de fond qui est
l'absence de rentabilité des entreprises
françaises la question voilà qu'elle
entrait répondu qu'il faut faire pour
s'attaquer à l'absence de rentabilité
boucher un trou si un autre trou qui se
créent à côté c'est vraiment à
l'économie les sapeur camember vous
savez vous mettez vous faites un trou et
on voit ce que vous vous demandez ce que
vous mettez la terre le type dit vous
auriez dû faire
trop beau mettra cette fois c'est celle
économies de deux boutons d'oborona
rhône a donné 40 milliards c'est très
bien mais c'est 40 milliards d'abord ces
quelques gouttes dans le 5e minute à la
mairie puis ensuite c'est le ça ne règle
en rien le problème de fond qui est
l'absence de rentabilité des entreprises
françaises compris il faut une réforme
totale du système et à l'instant la bce
qui annonce de nouvelles mesures de
soutien aux banques cette fois-ci merci
charles gave président de liberté
d'avoir été avec nous